devil fruits in one piece are pretty
simple you eat the fruit you get a
magical power and some of these powers
are pretty straightforward like just
turning into an animal While others are
so incredibly confusing and complex that
they feel like a whole different power
system in fact even hardcore fans might
not even realize that technically there
are an incredible 11 different
categories of devil fruits out there
each with their own unique rules special
abilities and powerups so let's break
down every single type of devil fruit in
the story starting off with some quick
Basics like what is a devil fruit now to
put it simply this is a real fruit that
you can actually eat with the only
difference being that it has inherited a
magical ability and to get that power
all a character needs to do is take a
single bite of that fruit and they will
have that new magic ability until the
day they die which is rather convenient
because we're shown over and over and
over again that these fruits taste like
this guy after he ate the world's
smelliest fruit however there's also
some danger with eating a devil fruit as
well because first it is really hard to
know what power you might be going to
get from a particular devil fruit you
might take a bite and get an awesome
lightning power or you might only be
able to turn into a cute little dog plus
there's only one of each power all
throughout the world technically so
sorry you and your friends can all be
firef fruit users at the same time the
biggest downside though is that of
course once you eat a devil fruit you
lose the ability to swim forever and so
if you do happen to fall in the water
well you're basically do doomed to drown
unless there is someone around you to
save you which honestly doesn't sound
all that bad until that is you remember
that like 90% of the one piece world is
actually covered by water so yeah it's a
pretty big risk especially for a pirate
who sails on the ocean like our main
character Luffy however most of these
abilities are simply so powerful that
eating the fruit is more than worth the
risk which brings us to our very first
main category of devil fruits which are
Zone fruits and these fruits are the
easiest to understand because they
simply allow the user to transform their
bodies from a human form into one
specific animal depending on that devil
fruit and while there are even more
benefits that we'll discuss in just a
moment on a basic level the user of
these fruits get all the benefits you
can imagine when you think about turning
into an animal for example this guy who
ate the giraffe fruit can now turn into
a full-on giraffe and can bash people
with his extra long neck or there's this
guy who ate the Falcon devil fruit so
naturally he can fly using his massive
Wings however that is only the most
basic ability of this fruit type because
in addition to a full animal
transformation the user can also
transform into a so-called Animal Human
hybrid form now as the name suggests
this basically turns you into a
combination of human and animal with
many of your animal characteristics for
example this guy who ate the leopard
fruit here we can see him in his normal
human form then his full animal form and
finally his Animal Human hybrid form and
a really skilled Zone user can change
Transformations almost instantly meaning
that you can greatly enhance your
fighting abilities by using the best
transformation suited to any situation
but if you thought that that was all
that there is to these fruits then just
listen to this because on top of
everything I have already mentioned all
Zone fruit users get automatic boost to
their natural speed strength endurance
and recovery but what's even crazier
though is that if your Zone fruit is a
meat eating animal like the leopard guy
that we just ched here then you also get
even more boosts in strength and
aggression due to that animal's natural
bloodthirsty nature just by eating the
fruit you basically get a giant power up
in your fighting abilities and now you
might be surprised to learn that there
are also two subcategories of Zone devil
fruits which get even more powerful but
before we discuss those let's talk about
the ultimate power up for a Zone fruit
user because with any devil fruit in one
piece the user can unlock a special
level of the devil fruit which is called
an Awakening and while it isn't 100%
exactly Spilled Out how to do this we
have some idea of how it works basically
when a person's mind and body catch up
with the natural will of a fruit you can
awaken the next level of that devil
fruit that basically means that you both
mentally embrace the spirit of the fruit
and your body is skilled enough in using
the fruit and to stick with the leopard
guy right here I guess you can say that
once he fully Embraces the natural will
or mindset of a leopard he was able to
awaken his devil fruit after using it
for many years and also of course when
regular Zone fruits awaken their devil
fruit they can get even higher boosts in
speed strength endurance and Recovery
which makes you an absolute Powerhouse
capable of fighting against even the top
tier fighters in the world but now
enough about regular Zone fruits let's
get to the even stronger forms of the
Zone category and the first of these are
so-called ancient zans which are still
animal devil fruits but they represent
animals or creatures from the distant
past for example dinosaurs woolly
mammoth and even a saber-tooth tiger and
just like regular zones these ancient
Zone fruit users can also transform into
the hybrid and full animal forms but
what separates these fruits from regular
ones is they get an even greater boost
to all of their physical abilities plus
they straight up get the awesome powers
of these ancient creatures which means
can have super hard scales massive Claws
and teeth or even just extreme size
which can all be super overpowered
during any fight but as strong as these
ancient zones are though they are
nothing compared to mythical zones and
honestly this might actually be the
single strongest category of devil
fruits in the entire story because these
fruits straight up allow the user to
become a mythical creature or legendary
being maybe the best example here is the
Emperor of the sea kaido whose mythical
devil fruit allows him to transform into
this awesome dragon I mean come on who
wouldn't want to be a super sized dragon
and to make things even better each
mythical Zone fruit also gets an extra
special ability on top of the regular
Zone physical boosts and Transformations
for example kaido here can create
Elemental attacks like his fiery blast
breath that can literally destroy
mountains summoning lightning strikes
and even create deadly tornadoes or wind
slashes and while this dragon fruit is
already simply overpowered other
examples of mythical zones are the
mythical niled Fox which allows the user
to shape shift and this mythical Phoenix
which lets him use this blue flames here
to magically heal himself and others and
mythical zones aren't just restricted to
animal likee creatures either because we
have seen for example the mythical
Buddha who can shoot out giant shock
waves from his palms so yeah truly a
very overpowered type of devil fruit
which is why we currently only have nine
of these confirmed in the story but now
while mythical zones may have these
strongest abilities the next main
category of devil fruits has without any
doubt the strongest base form that's
right it is time to discuss loia devil
fruits and for the longest time we
actually thought that these were
actually straight up the single most
powerful abilities in the story because
loia fruits turn your entire body into
the element or substance of that devil
fruit for example the lightning loia
fruit turns its user into a lightning
human and the magma fruit turns its
user's body into magma and now you might
be thinking well yeah sure that's cool
and all but is it really that
overpowered uh yeah because with these
Elemental Transformations loga users
cannot be hurt by regular attacks that's
because any regular attack will
literally just pass right through the
user for example punches go right
through this sand logia fruit user this
explosion just breaks this light fruit
user's body in half but he can quickly
reform himself and even a spear right
through the head doesn't even bother the
lightning fruit user here at all and so
really the only basic way to actually
damage them is by knowing their
Elemental weakness like water against
sand or rubber against lightning or if
you can't do that you can use special
anti-evil fruit Stones use hcky which is
a whole other power system we won't get
into here or have an even stronger devil
fruit or simp ilar elements but as if
that wasn't strong enough there are even
more special abilities of loia devil
fruit users as well because since their
body is transformed into an element they
can freely travel around by completely
turning into their substance for example
the light fruit user can become beams of
light to chase down opponent super
quickly or this snow logia user can
become a cloud of snow to sneak up
behind her enemies and while that is all
great for defense and movement loia
users can also produce and shoot out
their element to fight with at will some
great examples of this are this fire
loia user shooting out Fireballs the
light loia user shooting light bullets
and even this guy blasting off giant
magma fists to crush and burn his
enemies then loia users can straight up
make sorts of their element plus some
loia fruits like the swamp loia or the
darkness fruit here also let their users
trap people or even objects inside a
kind of pocket Dimension inside their
bodies which I mean is just in saying
that all of this is just the base
regular ability of a regular loio user
so now do you believe me that these are
the strongest base form devil fruits and
we haven't even gotten to the loia
ultimate power which is of course also
Awakening first though I do have to say
that loia Awakening has never been 100%
confirmed in the story yet however we
can kind of guess that loia Awakenings
turn their entire environment into that
person's Elemental ability and the best
example of this we've seen in the story
is when the ice and magma logia users
had a massive clash and left an entire
Islands permanently changed into half
Frozen mountains and half volcanic
Wasteland and so if we're considering
all of the categories of devil fruits
this next main category might actually
be the weakest however it contains what
I believe are some of the most powerful
individual devil fruits in the entire
story and so it is time to discuss
paramia fruits which can be broken into
three main subcategories as well and so
the first of these is body alteration
devil fruits which basically means a
devil fruit will change the user's body
in some very specific way and we have
seen examples of this all throughout the
story like this guy here who has become
a blade human and can transform any part
of his body into blades or this guy here
who can transform any part of his body
into super hard Diamond then can even
block attacks from the world's strongest
swordsman but maybe for an even better
better and crazier example we have this
woman who can turn any part of her body
into any weapon that she can imagine
swords guns massive Bazookas you name it
she can transform into it and I bet
you've never seen that power in any
other anime so far so yeah basically
body alteration paramas can change your
body in a ton of really creative ways
but the next subcategory is even more
powerful than this because next we have
environment manipulation Paramus and as
that name suggests instead of changing
the user's body these fruits give the
user the ability to affect the
environment around them in some way of
forance debts for example this Marine
Admiral can alter gravity to force
people to the ground or to even pull
down entire meteors from space I mean
that's pretty crazy right or another
perfect example is Luffy's former rival
who control magnetism which means that
he can pull or push any metal and create
metal body parts or or weapons but
that's of course just a start here
because the next subcategory of paramia
fruits lets the users produce and
control some sort of substance now this
is kind of similar to Loi abilities but
these users can only produce their given
substance and control it not completely
turn into that substance for example
this former warlord here can produce a
nearly endless amount of strength to
slash shoot bullets or even control
people like puppets then there's this
little girl who can produce these little
KB dungle balls and when she feeds them
to any animal it will let her command
these animals around and basically just
like zones or loia fruits the paramia
devil fruits also have an ultimate
Awakening in general this final PowerUp
allows the users to directly use their
powers on the environment and the
easiest way to explain that is to look
at some examples like the string fruit
user actually turning his entire
environment including buildings and the
ground into string that can then be
controlled or if you go back to the
magnetism user he can make parts of his
environment or even people magnetic to
trap them against a wall but what makes
paramia a little bit more confusing
though is that there are also some
paramas that don't exactly fit into any
of these categories so basically we'll
have to call this the other category for
example there is this little girl's
paramia fruit that is just absolutely
broken listen to this with a single
touch she can turn anyone into a little
toy
and then force them into a contract
where they have to obey her every
command and on top of that everybody
that that person ever knew instantly
forgets that they ever existed plus
thanks to the fruit this girl had her
age immediately Frozen which basically
makes her young forever so good luck
figuring out how to categorize that
devil fruit and then there's also this
guy's ability which can make this
magical Dome where he can do almost
anything that he wants within slicing
off body parts swapping personalities
and even teleport basically he can do it
all but the most amazing thing is that
this fruit has a special ability to
Grant Eternal youth or immortality to
one person however it does cost the
fruit users their life which again is
just such a broken ability that doesn't
really fit into any of the other boxes
however while these types of fruits are
really tough to categorize there is one
devil fruit that the author had to
officially create a brand new category
for and that was the most devil fruit
here which was originally going to be a
loia fruit but was later then changed to
a brand new category called special
paramia now as I just explained normally
paramia fruits get one of the abilities
we have mentioned above body adaptation
environment manipulation or producing a
substance but what's special about the
Mochi fruit is that it has both body
adaptation meaning his body can become
Mochi and he can produce Mochi which
basically almost makes it like a loia
fruit except that the user's actual body
isn't immune to regular attacks and even
Awakening this fruit lets the user
transform his entire environment into
sticky Mochi so it is literally the
perfect trifecta of paramia powers but
now maybe the most mysterious thing
about all of these devil fruits though
is that we aren't entirely sure where
they originally came from I mean we do
know that there is only one of each
specific fruit in the world at a time
and we also know that when a devil fruit
user dies their power is then
reincarnated into another fruit so that
a different person can eat it but so far
we don't know yet where they come from
they could have originally grown on some
kind of devil fruit tree or have been
made scientifically in the distant past
in fact this last explanation might
actually be the truth here because we
have seen two types of artificially made
devil fruits in the story the first type
is straight up evil because the
artificial smile devil fruits are
twisted versions of Zone fruits
basically a small fruit will give their
user some type of animal power but it
isn't even a regular Zone type
transformation instead you're kind of
permanently stuck with some kind of
animal part on your body kind of like
this guy who has a lion head as a
stomach or this bad guy who just always
has bad wings or my favorite are these
two who just I mean look so ridiculous
but maybe the worst thing here though is
that only one out of every 10 smile
fruits eaten actually give you an animal
power and the other nine just leave
people who ate them with a horrible
curse that they can only laugh for the
rest of their lives so yeah seriously
these things are completely messed up
however not all scientific devil fruits
are completely fla like this because the
world's best scientist basically
perfectly recreated the mythical dragon
fruit which gave this boy the exact same
powers of the legendary dragon only in a
different color on top of that this same
scientist was actually able to extract
devil fruit DNA and recreate the powers
in genetically engineered clones which
does mean that in theory he could make
copies of any devil fruit power in the
world which is honestly a really scary
thought like could you imagine how
terrifying an entire Army of devil fruit
users would be we could have 10 Ultra
destructive lightning fruit users or 50
mythical phoenixes flying around or
worst of all what if there were 100
pocket fruit users to trap everyone in
their creepy body pockets and these are
just three of some of the most insanely
powerful and also wacky devil fruit
powers in one piece and if you want to
learn about literally every single devil
fruit ability that does exist in the
story you can check out that video right
here Shanks for watching and I will see
you in the next one